okay
that's the one
I guess I was in the middle of uh just
write down some things that we'll need
from last time so basically the goal for
this talk was so if you remember from
the last bit box I defined this notion
called spectral Independence
I showed you a couple techniques for
establishing spectral Independence and
then I stated some theorems that I never
approved or even Justified at all which
is that this property of the
distribution actually says anything
about mixing okay so the goal of this
talk is to give you some some intuition
behind that okay
um okay so maybe let's just recall just
a few pieces of notation so recall that
the so if I have a Markov chain say
Global Dynamics then it has an
Associated quadratic form which I for
which I you know measured a local
variation of a function it's given by
this this formula it's not so important
what this is and I'll write I'll
actually rewrite this later on but if
you want something concrete this is it
and then what we're really interested in
in terms of you know being able to
control these mixing times as these
functional inequalities so I look at the
comparison the global variance will
function with respect to the local
variances or say the global entropy of a
entropies and so okay and I guess I was
in the middle of writing so just
recalling what is spectral Independence
and again for this talk let's just work
on the Boolean Cube for convenience
so the circular dependence just says
that the largest eigenvalue of a certain
influence Matrix or correlation
conditional influence Matrix or
correlation Matrix is upper bounded and
just to make sure we're on the same page
just recall that the entries of this
influence Matrix
they're given by
influences
um
okay so now let me just recall what we
saw yesterday we're starting
connection to fast mixing
so we had the following two theorems so
the first theorem
because
essentially two to 11 now although they
were all also precursors of this from
the high dimensional expander Community
which is that if
mu and all the conditionals
are
you know sexually independent
then
the the special gap of the blower
Dynamics
is lower bounded by one over and
the OnePlus 8 okay
this is the first result and the second
result
something that will allow you so control
something more fine-grained so you can
get a control on even entropy so
so assume
so spectral Independence
well really the same condition as above
and if I make two additional assumptions
then we can get a much better bound so
if I assume that it's uh satisfies
hey
Global
Markov property
step two
they found a degree graph
okay
and third is the more slightly more
technical assumption but is necessary
for something like a standard log so
we'll have inequality
um that all
marginals
let's say our constants constant order
um even under conditioning
if I make these three assumptions
then actually
I have like a locks level of constant or
P new lower bounded by
order one over n and really get bounce
for all of the functional inequalities
that I want and in particular I'll get n
log n mixing okay so my goal for this
talk is to give you essentially a
complete proof of this although so I
guess I first say if you recall from uh
I think it reads talk she talked about
the equivalence between
two Notions of high dimensional
expansion one which is based off of
something a local spectral expansion
which is we saw yesterday is equivalent
to spectral Independence
there's that notion of high dimensional
expansion and it's equivalent to
something called random walk expansion
which is essentially mixing for these
blocks so it turns out if you take that
proof or that theorem and you sort of
inductively apply it you can prove this
um but I guess my goal for this talk is
or one goal is to sort of show you like
a more just purely probabilistic proof
of this okay and then it will be useful
to do it that way so that I can also
let's give you some semblance of an idea
of how to how you can do this
okay
we were much more hind state
so
Okay so
so here I'm just assuming only special
Independence but I can only deduce a
bound on the Gap and the spectral
dependence goes in the exponent of n
here if I make the same assumption but I
also add two more assumptions I get one
over n and I guess of course there's
some dependence on the spiritual
dependence but it's not in the exponent
of n
for sure yeah
but even the third assumption will
assume that every marginal of SATA one
does that say anything about it this is
exponentially small but that you still
didn't want log log to kill that kind
so so the main one probably can still be
yeah
other questions
okay so before we like uh sort of invoke
spectral Independence let's first ask
ourselves how to do this for product
measures okay so I guess you know the
cool kids would probably do Fourier
analysis or even stochastic calculus but
I'll do something a bit more uh
bare-handed
so
let's just do it for product measures
is green okay or is it too
so first thing let me just say that
okay when I so I keep using the word
mysteriously form it's like a local
variance and there's actually really I
mean if you look at this you say oh it
kind of looks like it I'm comparing the
variance across slipping coordinate but
there is really a formal sense to which
that's true so I can rewrite this
digital form as follows
so another way to rewrite the staircase
form at least for Global Dynamics
let's now just say hit it with the same
function
this is really equal to
so I am taking an expectation I can
think of as taking an expectation over a
uniformly random coordinate
an expectation
over an assignment of all vertices on
all the other coordinates
only appropriate marginal distribution
of the variance
under after conditioning on everything
except the ith coordinate
of the function okay so let me help you
parse this to make sure we're on the
same page here so you should really
think of this expectation over everybody
except I it's just coming from this
summation here when I'm taking
expectation over a whole configuration
and then this average over the choice of
coordinate is really just the average
choice of which which coordinate I'm
flipping in the in the Dynamics
and then I guess the rest of it is just
calculation but this is sort of a formal
sense in which you can see this really
is a local variance so I it's a
yeah
okay so really what plant query means is
that
variance Global variance approximately
factorizes
this is surrounded by so this is
the bunk arrays equivalent
the same thing as the
global global variance factorizes
sometimes it's called
factorization
or tensorization
appearance
or less or like say an approximate
version
okay okay so how do you do it for
product measures so really it's just the
following
Lemma
which is I think it's like a very nice
like exercise and like convexity it's
just it's something very generic it says
that if
basically you know for all measures mu
and Nu
and for all functions f
you look at the variance
under with respect to the product of Neo
new F this is at most
so I can take the expectation over a
draw from mu
the variance
under Drive New
Tau Sigma
plus the same thing for example now on
the outside I take a draw from new
variance with respect to a draw from mu
or the same quantity
and also the same thing for entropy
and this is really crucial uses that
they're independent of each other it's
first off is this notation okay is
notation clear and also what this means
or
yeah so this is a like a nice exercise
in convexity but basically if you have
this Lemma then you just inductively
apply it if you have a product measure
right all the corners are independent so
I'm just going to peel off one
coordinate at a time
and what you'll what you'll get so
by induction
or
product measures
you'll get basically the optimal
constant there which is you know say a
variance
news are compounded by n times
leadership
that's like the optimal constant okay
and it really is then there's like
there's no extra hidden constants or
anything
and let me just say very briefly if you
so this thing also holds for entropy
and if you have this sort of entropy
factorization
let's say we have
a slightly different constant row
entropy
mobile entity of a function
is at most the
expected local entropies so I minus I
then this in a complete Black Box manner
so first this implies another nice
exercise in convexity implies a modified
logs level of inequality
foreign
at least the
bro
I also apply the standard Lux obliv
inequality
with constant at least rho times
essentially
a constant depending on how bounded your
marginals okay so what this really yeah
this is a bit of a technical point but
I'm just saying that if I can establish
something like entropy factorization or
tensorization of entropy I can also
deduce
on these kinds of things
but I don't want to get into much
details there
but questions on how to do product
measures because from now from that from
here on we're going to sort of try to
generalize this to like approximate
versions and then use spectral
Independence
right exactly yeah that's like at least
one really useful
okay
so now
so in this language I want to First
reformulate the theorems this serum
looks very spectral right line algebraic
I'm just going to reformulate it in
terms of variance factorization okay so
the that'll be also sort of suggests the
proof
probably improved
okay
so let me restate the 11 loud theorem so
well
restated
so okay so I'm right in terms of
variance factorization so I'm gonna have
the global
Global variance on the left-hand side
we have the local variances on the right
hand side
and I guess now it's a question of what
constant to put here
so it's going to have the following form
it's gonna have a product form base
we're going to do induction basically
but basically yeah basically it's
exactly this expression here so take a
product
J from 0 to n minus two
of one minus 1 plus ETA
maybe your approximates like
exponentials then you can
see that it's really just this
okay
okay questions
okay so like the proof for
in some similar sense to the proof of
product measures we're going to do it by
induction
so I first I claim
that it suffices
proof
I guess I'll probably saying quality
star which is really just sort of the
the one step so you think of it like
here I'm not conditioned on anything
and here I've conditioned on N minus 1
many coordinates right so instead of
going from zero to minus one it's gonna
condition on one indication on two
condition on three and so on so I just
need to prove so I claim that it suffice
to prove the following inequality that
if I look at
up to this Factor
one minus 1 plus 8 over n
the global variance factorizes slightly
factorizes as well if I take expectation
over the coordinate I but now on
expectation over only the assignment to
only that one vertex okay
and I look at now just a slightly
localized variance
I find that this suffices
why because then I can iterate this
apply the star inequality to each of the
conditional measures right because
remember I'm assuming that all
conditional measures are spectrally
independent right
is that okay
particular
so
if I so if I apply
if I apply
star like K times
I guess I'm writing this out because I'm
going to need it later if I apply this K
times then I'll get that
yeah look at the product
over K from 0 to K minus one one minus
which is
n minus J
Global variance
it's at most
the expectation of a random subset
K coordinates
expectation over an assignment to those
coordinates
or into the correct marginal
distribution
of the sort of localized variances
and of course the K the case k equals m
minus 1 is the claim
okay
okay so let's see at least like sort of
sketch the proof of star I think it's a
bit more just more of a calculation but
I'll show you like at least intuitively
why this is related to like correlation
inequalities okay
okay
where's the proof of star
Okay so
the first thing that you would do you
know if you're doing conditioning right
I have a global variance and I add good
conditioning as I would apply the law of
global rates so a lot of total variants
so what it means is just
if I
you know if I decompose my measure as
just like a mixture like say
with expectation over Pi Sigma y of the
conditional measure
it's like I'm decomposing my measure
then where every functions and for every
function f
the global variance of that function
can be decomposed as
the variance of the expectation plus the
expectation of the variance right so I
have the
patient
over I and sigma I
have the variance
and plus
usually the most annoying term which is
the variance
with respect to a random choice of I and
sigma I
have now basically the expectation
and a similar identity holds for entropy
and so on
I can look at this thing and compare
with what I want from Star
when I rewrite star
it's really the same thing it's
equivalent to saying that
basically this thing is exactly what I
have on the right hand side here
this is equivalent to saying that
I look at
all right disappearance here
variance under
random Choice supported I and an
assignment to that coordinate
expectation
with respect to the conditional measure
upper bounded by one plus eight Over N
times the global variance
I'm just going to pause here I guess
it's a bit more of a calculation but um
I've really done nothing fancy
I guess at this point I could just tell
you that okay so this is already
starting to look very much like
spectral Independence you can think of
this if you think of this one over n
here is really just accounting for the
fact that I picked a random coordinate
here
and this one plus Ada so
if you think of say this being this is
like roughly that L2 Norm
function f with respect to a suitable
Norm so it's starting already starting
to look somewhat similar
to this but
not so clear how to interpret this
quantity here okay so
if I'm a bit irresponsible I would just
say you know exercise you know it's a
calculation and just be done with it
but let me just give you a little bit of
tuition without having to write
everything out myself
all right
let me just um
just reproduce it here so I want
I want
variance under a random coordinate I
a random assignment to that coordinate
expectation
under the conditional measure
function f is at most
n
is the global variance
which I'm really thinking of this as
like
okay
so now is where I'm going to start
interpreting this linear algebraically
because I have to get an eigenvalue at
some point right so what does this
really mean
so one way to interpret what this means
is okay so this thing here this is
really like if I imagine f is being a
two to the N dimensional vector
this is really an inner product
yeah
and this variance is kind of like I'm
picking like a random One of These Guys
these inner products and squaring it
right so this here on the right hand
side so the left hand side is
I really think it's roughly equal to
if I pick a random
coordinate I a random assignment to
Sigma I
of
this inner product
so we're now really viewing things as
vectors
like big vectors
but I can of course rewrite this you
know by pulling it out of everything out
this is equal to
I've transpose of now a matrix
very big Matrix
I'm just interpreting this variance as
like a quadratic form okay we have some
Matrix inside
now this is a very big Matrix but it's a
low rank Matrix because I only have like
n or two n many terms here
it's about like a rank and to the N
Matrix
and it's also I guess PSD or whatever so
you can just use now I can sort of
compress this Matrix down right because
because really now it's like
I'm comparing it with the global L2 Norm
of f so it's really just asking for like
the norm of this Matrix
right
so now you can just use the fact that
then just use like this basically an
alternative effect that sort of the
spectrum
let's say like a a transpose
is equal to the Spectrum
a transpose a
maybe up to like the multiplicity of the
zero eigenvalue but you only care about
the norm anyways so yeah
so
so then
Matrix you would get instead and now
just really inner products pairwise
inner products between these vectors and
if you calculate everything out you'll
get you'll see you get like a
correlation up in the intervenes
those are just like some intuition like
how you would carry out the calculation
but you know I don't want to
for you
so here I've only pinned one variable
pick a random coordinate I pin only that
coordinate
and I still have n minus one free
coordinates and each of them is has this
measure
other question
sure yes so there are there are versions
of say like factorization of entropy
where you pick I could pick a random
block of subset of vertices and there
are analogs of that and you can also
introduce like mixing for those using
spectral events
okay so really like yeah if you believe
me that now like these two things are
really the same
they're the same then we've proven Star
by induction I have my theorem and then
we're done okay this is like an
alternative way that's like sort of like
there's there's no like or I guess a
little bit less linear algebra
anyways
so I mean I guess
yeah but um
I mean they're examples where even like
if you have bad special dependence who
are just like a very small number of
things it's still like Market chains
very poorly mixing yeah I'm really like
I have to apply because now we have to
take an average over these things right
so I didn't put the worst case like if
I'm gonna combine terms right
so I really need like a worst case thing
I mean you can make it slightly average
case but not to like maybe not to the
extent that you think
foreign
you get some kind of averaging here but
it's not like an average choice of
um like uh anywhere like it's not over
an average choice of this one it's I
take a worst case towards of this but I
get the average the ordering in which I
do this
so there's like a little bit of
averaging but
um but I mean I think he has some
interesting applications of this but
um
I think I'll let him you know speak for
that
um but um yeah I I just want to keep
things simple like just
more questions
okay
okay so now
what I want to do
I want to give you some idea if
how to do this how did this
foreign
okay so I guess here's the question like
all right it's just really the question
of like uh you know how you would think
about this which is like where in this
analysis was lossy or well another way
to put it is you know so there's a
reason I wrote down this inequality here
this General version okay like perhaps a
more suggestive question is just for
what values of K is this actually fine
so maybe
say more precisely what I mean by this
so
really what I claim
somehow things are very good for like
small J right because I'm I'm only
losing like one minus a penny a little
bit things are only getting really bad
if like J is getting close to N
right so here is the observation
or let's say I assume K is like
equal to Theta n or
some constant
I get to pick
to have this thing so then
right so
what I claim is that um
really we have
so up to some constant
we have very good factorization of the
global entropy
with respect to a random subset of
linear sites
foreign
just because
you know this is sort of I'm look really
looking at from jauling up to only say
Theta n
ude sting
this is approximately say exponential if
you calculate it all out minus one plus
Theta what kind of log of
1 over Theta
so Theta is a consonant if I choose
Theta to be a constant then I get very
good factorization so really things are
very good that's for the bottom okay
so a dynamical perspective on this what
this says is that if I run the following
crazy Dynamics which is in each step I
pick a random subset of one minus Theta
and many vertices so a huge number of
vertices
I resample all of them
and this really crazy random walk is
going to mix in one step or constant
number of steps
as it should
intuitively but
um but even that's like you know
non-trivial okay
but that's what this says
of course
here I still have some like global-ish
looking variants right because I still
have order n many vertices remain
I don't want to use keep using spectral
Independence to further decompose these
variances
so this is exactly how we're going to
use where these two extra assumptions
are going to come in
so what you really hope for is that so
now imagine let's say you're looking at
really now like a like a graph type
model right so for for instance
maybe like matching as we saw earlier or
like independent sets or something
so what I've done here is I pick a
random subset of vertices and I've
assigned stuff to them I've assigned
plus minus one to them effectively I've
just deleted them from the graph
right so I have a big graph of n
vertices but I've killed tons and tons
of vertices a constant fraction on my
vertices are killed
so in particular if this graph is sparse
what I would expect to happen if I
killed that many vertices
is that this graph should shatter into a
bunch of small pieces
and intuitively it helps me factorize
this variance much much better than you
would expect otherwise
is that rough intuition I mean I'll say
more clearly
um
how exactly formalized this but this is
roughly where we're going to go
any questions but the plan
[Music]
explain again
yeah very good question yeah yeah so
let's forget the factorization thing for
now okay so
so first you believe that if I apply
this K times I get this kind of
inequality where
you know I take a product of Decay and
now I'm sampling a subset of K vertices
and I'm yeah okay
so while I'm saying is that if I take K
to the order n not exactly n but Theta
of n
then the coefficient I get here
you know this you think of this as being
safe the spectral gap of the correspond
Dynamics something special that you mix
in life
okay sorry no no okay maybe not order
one but yeah but just like very very
fast yeah sorry I was being very loose
Goosey about it but um
uh this you makes very much much like
very very fast
um
[Music]
okay so so what do we want to do now
I wanna so we want to control
basically this
variance
after I've conditioned on the values of
linearly many vertices
and since everything has that
expectation it's kind of okay if only
the balanceful like with high
probability basically so let's work
please
so basically this is Hope
[Music]
high probability
the choice of this of the vertices s
this mu condition on the assignment on S
it's going to factorize this factorize
the products
so maybe let's call it
say
mu of so slow conditioning on everything
in this but now I'm looking at a smaller
subset of vertices
each
let's say where
where let's say U1 QT
or the
the maximal connected components
of the induced somewhere after I've
deleted those S vertices
so of course I can always do this
by the conditional Independence
assumption because if these connected
components they're maximal then and they
don't have you know there are no edges
between them so there's no like
influence between them
what we really care about is not only
that you know I can do this but you know
I have many components and all of these
components are small
so
that's that I guess we don't really care
that there are many components but we
want all of these to be small which
necessarily means that there are many
but um such that you know
yes
even more explicit on like why this is
good for us just recall that a lemon I
showed previously
have the variance
for like the product two measures
factorizes perfect
so I can just apply this to each of
these components
and once I've gotten down if it really
is the case that for instance all of
these components are constant order
right
then I can just have a constant sized
graph like it's going to mix and you
know a constant time this I think
there's nothing uh
nothing really left to do at that point
right that's really the hope if I buy a
small graph sense kind of okay and
really I just need to ensure that the
graph shatters
and that's where I'm going to use
the bounded to greenness
picture
as far as it was that many random
restrictions it's simplifies
I guess I don't show with me my early
stopping you're not stopping the market
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're early
you're stopping this early because at
some point this becomes too lossy yeah
yeah or like you know say login is fine
but you know yeah order one ideally but
you know everything is an expectation so
it's it's it'll be fine
yeah okay so
thank you
I want to state
the shattering number which
really uses the bound degrees
foreign
so if
the G
as maximum degree
says constant
[Music]
um
uniformly random
vertices choose say Theta and many
vertices okay so I'm going to kill off
order and many vertices
and for every vertex
every
l
the probability
that okay so
SV here is going to be the size of the
map is this is the maximal connected
component that contains V after I kill
off those vertices okay I'll write it
more slowly in a sec so the probability
that the size of the connected
components in containing b equal to l is
at most there's some constants
Delta times 1 minus Theta
yeah
so and let me just say
this is maximum
connected
opponents
then do subref after deleting s
so in particular if I choose my sort of
and again I'm assuming the degree is
bounded so if I can choose Theta here to
be a constant
and now I have you know exponentially a
small probability that my component is
large
so an expectation is of constant order
with very high probabilities of like
login order that's it
okay so I'll come back to this in a
moment that's just like very quickly
you want to see how to do this
question I mean like the proof of this
what do you mean yeah sure
um I was thinking like should I just
like right out to like the
doing all this business I guess I don't
have I don't have that much more
material to cover anyways so I guess I
could just do whatever I want
um
okay good okay so okay I'll see okay
yeah so where does property three come
in so I guess
so turns out okay if you just want
spectral Gap order one over n you don't
need property three
okay the property three is really just
so that I can get control on entropy
based off of
like correlations which is like for
variance instead that's really it so I
don't need property if I want one over
in gap
S I also need it because I need to be
able to say that you know so remember
this star inequality
so we want that one minus
I want to put entropy
f
not most say
entropy
so this this is ideally so this if you
have variants here this is exactly what
you get from spectral Independence we
want this for entropy but
in order to get that from spectral
dependency you also have to use the
marginal boundaries in this inequalities
otherwise so I guess it's also a
question of like you know
if you change your assumptions sure like
then it just kind of goes through but
then you need to establish a stronger
thing
this is like a classical thing you can
always like convert spectral Gap to
entropy at like some loss depending on
you know like the minimum
uh probably
okay
so I guess
yeah so I guess that typically is a it's
a more okay I mean those are typically
more calculations but it's like I mean
typically one way you can bound is like
okay I have a Vertex have I seen this
boundary degree right so for any choice
of setting outside the neighborhood I
can compute the margin of that vertex
explicitly and I just do an average I
can bound it yeah
silver one
yes so for something so Okay so
yesterday I talked about a couple
techniques for establishing it for
something like it really is like model
dependent so for some the easing model
on a boundary graph you want to use like
decay of correlations
I guess really okay yeah so I guess if
you guys already believe this then
nothing left very little left for me to
do I mean I can just very briefly sketch
out like some of the like how you like
sort of combine all these things
together but after that I guess maybe
I'll just open up the questions or give
some time back to everyone
okay
so
questions
as I should also mention this kind of
shattering type limit for sparse grass
is like a very it's a very useful thing
it's not just like marker chains like
apparently people even in distributed
algorithms use this thing
maybe I should also put a citation so I
guess the version of it we used is due
to boards
okay
okay so I guess I'll just do the okay so
roughly
outline of calculations
sort of
I'm going to start with of course my
Global variance
I'm going to use
this thing right here
say it's upper bounded by say a constant
times
the expectation of a random set of
vertices of linear size
no I think it's an expectations I'm
going to do shattering so my shadowing
foreign
more expectations okay expectation over
so
you
think
and now I just use something like use
like any Punk or you want like you can
even have like a very lossy punter
inequality here it's so long as sort of
the probability of having a large set
sort of is much smaller than like the
bad bound you use for the pancreating
colors
companies
I'm not sure it's that valuable to keep
doing this but
um that's really it hopefully I've
Illustrated the rough idea or intuition
yes I'll open up to questions
usually that's like kind of like baked
into your distribution right I mean it's
like
like all like the classical Commodore
models or not all the like many of them
like independent sets or something or
uh
or you know matchings clearly if I have
two disconnected graphs like a matching
here it's not going to affect the
matching here
right so Spanish tree does not work but
Spanish tree is the special case where
like the spectral independent is so
strong that I don't even need this
one yeah but there's a kind of
miraculous thing that if you have zero
spectral Independence then actually the
variance you can get entropy bounds from
the variance I guess like it
yeah there's like a very like a like a
convexity kind of thing that happens we
have zero
I still like improve it even further but
in terms of getting mlsi all this is
like you add like extra complexity so
for the local entropy contraction
because this has like interpretation any
HDX language I thought
I feel saying you can skip all the if
all links
yeah basically right I mean you can
always present HDX language basically
it's like after I've taken a link
like say s then the remaining complex is
really like I don't know what the right
it's like direct product like what's the
it's like product of you know
whatever notation people use for it but
like uh smaller complexes
I mean you should think of it like uh
now like the local box will have like a
bunch of complete uh bipartite structure
connecting these uh smaller complexes
so it's like even better expanding
and in this case because of like the
global market property it's like a true
product right
yeah it really is like these are these
are really just completely independent
of each other yeah that's right
right you only knows that on some level
they have very good those links have
very good extensions can you also like
oh you're saying like Okay because this
is like a product of measures then maybe
just the spectral dependence is like
much better for that without uh
appealing to that appears I thought this
is saying uh
much better right so I guess the the
trouble is though is because first off
again this is a this doesn't hold for
all s right this is like for averages
yeah most tests the other issue here is
that okay you could you could study like
the spectral dependence of this thing
right and maybe it's much better than
the one you get normally right but you
know if your spectral plan is even like
two you're gonna get a bad bound or like
three You're Gonna Get N cubed already
so
yeah somehow it doesn't um
oh okay sure yeah so I guess I can I can
I mean I guess the real Workhorse is
just like a sort of accounting
accounting number that says you know if
I have a Vertex I count the number of
subgraphs and do subgraphs that are
connected and that would contain that
vertex okay so that's like really the so
really the I guess
so this was proved using this but okay
the real Lemma there was like um
so we're all
Max degree
three for all d
or vertices V for all L the number
connected components
size
L containing
sorry
connected induced
subgraphs
painting
see
something like e times e Delta l
Ines
okay and this is actually not super hard
to prove basically it's like instead of
counting connected components which is a
little bit challenging I just connect
trees I count trees that contain B
and if I want to count trees then in
some sense the worst case you can do is
is look at the infinite tree because
having Cycles is only going to reduce
your number of trees reducing number of
edges only going to reduce the number of
trees so the worst case you even know
the worst case here is the infinite tree
so
yeah that's awesome
one so for the style
any final questions
thanks
thanks everyone